I think if you focus on trying to have
an impact on the world I think you're
going to end up deeply unhappy but does
that matter
like what may happen happiness matter it
may happen as a byproduct
but I think that you should strive to
find your own personal happiness and
then measure how that manifests as it
relates to society and to other people
but if the answer to those questions is
zero that doesn't make you less of a
person no 100 but then the other way is
there are times when you need to
sacrifice your own personal happiness
the force for a bigger thing for that
you've created yeah if you're if you're
in a position to do it I think some
folks are tested Elon is probably the
best example and
it must be
really really hard to be him
um really hard I have
enormous
levels of empathy and care for him I
really love him as a person because I
just see that it's not like it's not
that fun
and and he has these ways of
Being Human that in his position I just
think are so dear that if he never I
just hope he never loses them just a
simple example like two days ago
I don't know why but I went on Twitter
and I saw the perfume thing so I'm like
ah [ __ ] it I'm just gonna go buy some
perfume so I bought his perfume the
burnt hair thing yeah
and I said and I emailed him the receipt
and I'm like all right you got me for a
bottle
um and he responded in like eight
seconds and it was just a smiley face or
whatever yeah just deeply normal things
that you do amongst people that are just
so nobody sees that
you know what I mean but it would be
he deserves for that stuff to be seen
because the rest of his life is so
brutally hard yeah
um he's just a normal guy that is just
caught in this Ultra Mega vortex
why do you think there's so few elons
it's an extremely
lonely set of trade-offs
because to your point if you get tested
so if you think about it again
probabilistically there's eight billion
people in the world maybe 50 of them get
put in a position where they are
building something of such colossal
importance that they even have this
choice
and then of that 50 maybe 10 of them are
put in a moment where they actually have
to make a trade-off
you know you're not going to be able to
see your fam I'm making this up you're
not going to be able to see your family
you're not you know you're going to have
to basically move into your factory
you're gonna have to sleep on the floor
but here's the outcome energy
Independence and you know resource
abundance and peace you know a massive
peace dividend
and then he says to himself I don't know
that he did because I've never had this
yeah you know what that's worth it
and like and then you look at your kids
and you're like
I'm making this decision I don't know
how to explain that to you yeah you want
to be in that position there's no
there's no amount of money where I would
want to be in that position so that
takes an enormous fortitude and a moral
compass
that he has and that's what I think
people need to need to appreciate about
that guy it's also on the first number
he said it's confusing that there's 50
people or 10 people
like that are put in the position to
have that level of impact it's unclear
that that has to be that way it seems
like there could be much more
there should be there's definitely
people with the potential
um but you know think about think about
his journey you know his mom had to
leave a very complicated environment
moved to Canada moved to Toronto you
know a small apartment uh just north of
Bain Bloor you know if you've ever been
to Toronto
um I remember talking to her about this
apartment it's so crazy because I used
to live like around the corner from that
place and raise these three kids and
just have to so
how many people are going to start with
those boundary conditions
you know and really grind it out
it's just very few people in the end
that
um will have the resiliency to stick it
through where you don't give in to the
self-doubt
and so it uh you know it's a really it's
just a really hard set of boundary
conditions where you can have 50 or 100
of these people that's why they needed
to be really they need to be really
appreciated
yeah well that's true for
all humans that
follow the the threat of their passion
and do something beautiful in this world
that could be in a small scale or a big
scale appreciation is a
that's a gift you give to the other
person but also a gift to yourself
that's somehow it becomes like this uh
contagious thing I went to this you are
so right you just like it my my brain
just lit up because yesterday I went to
an investor day of my friend of mine
um describe Brad gerstner and you know
on the one very reductive World Brad and
I are theoretically competitors but
we're not he makes his own set of
decisions I make my own set of decisions
we're both trying to do our own view of
what is good work in the world
but he's been profoundly successful and
it was really the first moment of my
adult life where I could sit in a moment
like that
and really be appreciative of his
success and not feel less then
and so you know little selfishly for me
but mostly for him as well
I was so proud to be in the room that's
my friend that guy plays poker with me
every Thursday he is crushing it that's
awesome you know and that's the it's a
it's a really amazing feeling